SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALL RIGHT, GIL. ARCHULETTA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE
SPEAR. BRADFORD. PIERROT
COURTESY. DAILY. DODD. THERE AS
Ó. HAGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ.
GROVE. BUT DATO JONES. LAIRD.
LIMÓN REQUIRE MENJIVAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. WHEN NILO. A CHILD BOOK.
TODAVÍA PORTANTINO ROD. RUBIO.
THEY ARE TOE. DINNER. SMALL
QUIVERS STERN. HAMBURG. AHA!
WIENER. WILK. MEMBERS OF QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAP CHAPLIN SISTER MICHELE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
LET US REMEMBER THAT WE ARE
ALWAYS IN GOD'S PRESENCE. GOD OF
MERCY AND COMPASSION. AND THIS
INTERNATIONAL HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE WEEKEND. ONCE AGAIN,
WE ARE REMINDED HERMAN'S
INHUMANITY TO MAN MAKES
COUNTLESS MILLIONS MOURN. WE ASK
FOR THE GRACE TO RECOGNIZE THE
DESTRUCTIVE PREJUDICES IN
OURSELVES. THAT LED TO THE
DEHUMANIZATION OF THOSE WE DEEM
DIFFERENT FROM US. WE ASK FOR
THE GRACE TO OVERCOME THE
IRRATIONAL FEARS. THAT CAUSE US
TO MISJUDGE OTHERS LEADING TO
VIOLENCE AND IRREPARABLE HARM.
WE ASK FOR THE GRACE TO LIVE
EACH DAY WITH AN ATTITUDE OF
COMPASSION. CREATING AN
ATMOSPHERE OF HOSPITALITY AND
WELCOME WHERE ALL CAN THRIVE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COMMON GOOD.
MAY EVERY STORY SHARED BEING
IMPETUS TO ACTION. THAT ENSURES
THAT THE WORDS NEVER AGAIN ARE
MORE THAN PIOUS SENTIMENT. WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. PLEASURE
BELIEVE.
MEMBERS. PRIVILEGE OF THE
FLOORS, BUT WE'RE GOING TO PASS
AT THIS MOMENT. MOVING TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEAN RED. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD BE DEEMED RAT.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES TEAM RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
WILL BE STRICKEN FROM THE DAILY
FILE ITEMS TWO THROUGH 52.
INTRODUCTIONS. AND FIRST READING
THE BILLS. BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ. CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FOUL. WE HAVE SENATE SECOND
READING FILE ITEM ONE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 254. THANK YOU. NOW I'M
MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING. FIRST UP IS FALL ITEM.
64 SENATOR AMBERG. HE IS NOT AT
HIS DESK, OKAY? SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 26 BY
SENATOR HAMBURG AND ACCURATELY
INTO HEALTH PROFESSIONS.
NUREMBERG FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES.
THIS MEASURE IS INTENDED TO AT
LEAST IN SOME SMALL WAY. ADDRESS
THE DEARTH OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. IT'S A
SCHOLARSHIP FOR THOSE WHO COMMIT
TO SERVING IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS IN
EXCHANGE FOR A SCHOLARSHIP.
URGENT. I VOTE THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? MENDOCINE, UN
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I BROUGHT A DEAL. I LET OH,
I ASHBY AYE, ATKINS. BECKER.
BLACK SPEAR, BRADFORD. HI
CAVIAR, Ó. GOOD TO SEE. DOLLY!
I DIED. DURAZO. I ADMIN. GLASER.
GONZALEZ. AYE, GROVE. OR DATO.
AYE, JONES. LAYERED BY LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE HI, JABBAR. MEN. I
NEWMAN I WHEN I KNEEL Ó. AYE. I
AM. AYE, PORTANTINO ROD. HI,
RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO TOÀN SKINNER
BY SMALL QUIVERS. AYE, STERN.
HAMBURG. AYE, WAHAHA. BY WIENER.
AYE, WILK. BYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER. I
BLAKE SPEAR. CAVIAR Ó. BYE.
ORTEZ. EDMUND I GROVE. AYE,
JONES. MENJIVAR. AYE,
PORTANTINO. STERN. 34 NO. ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON
THE FALL ITEM. 66 SENATOR
WIENER. HE'S PREPARED SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. SENATE BILL 85 BY
SENATOR WIENER INACTIVATED
IMMIGRATION SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES, CENTERVILLE 85 WILL
EXTEND CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
FOR REFUGEES AND ASYLUM. PLEASE,
WHO ARE SETTLED IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PAYS FOR 90 DAYS OF CASE
MANAGEMENT, AND THIS IS ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN GRANTED
REFUGE HERE GRANTED ASYLUM HERE,
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
SETTLED IN COMMUNITIES HAVE
HOUSING HAVE SUPPORT SO THAT
THEY CAN INTEGRATE AND SUCCEED.
90 DAYS IS NOT ENOUGH OTHER
STATES SUPPLEMENT THAT SB 85
WILL ADD AN ADDITIONAL 90 DAYS
OF CASE MANAGEMENT WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF EXTENDING BY
ANOTHER 180 DAYS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. IN CHINA AND SECRETARY
POLICE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ALREADY GIL. AYE, ARCHULETTA.
AYE, ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. I BECKER
I BLAKE SPEAR. BRADFORD. I W R O
HIÂU ORTEZ E. DOLLY! DODD. I
TERRAZZO. AYE, EGGMAN. AYE,
GLASER. I GONZALEZ HIGHGROVE.
HER 0.0. AYE. JONES, LAIRD. AYE,
LIMÓN. I MEAN, MCGUIRE HI,
JABBAR. MEN. AYE, NEWMAN. I WHEN
NILO. KOBO. BUT HERE AYE,
PORTANTINO. RATHER AYE, RUBIO.
AYE, SEYARTO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL QUIVERS. AYE, STERN.
HAMBURG. I HAB AYE, WIENER. I
WILL. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BLACK SPEAR.
ORTEZ E. DOLLY! GROVE. JONES.
MENJIVAR. AYE. WHEN HELLO. PHÐ
VOGUE. PORTANTINO SEE OUR TOE.
STERN. 29 NOS. ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES REMEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING
ON THE FOLLOW ITEM. 69 SENATOR
WIENER. HE'S PREPARED SECRETARY
YOU MAY READ. SENATE BILL 312 BY
SENATOR WEINER AND ACTUALLY INTO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, SP 312 IS
CLEAN UP FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION
TO LET SENSIBILITY 886, WHICH A
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED IN 2022 SP 86
CREATED A SECRET EXEMPTION FOR
STUDENT HOUSING ON CAMPUS AT UC
CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM
WITH OUR UC CSU COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS HOUSING UNSTABLE WE
NEED MORE ON CAMPUS STUDENT
HOUSING, WE NEED MORE QUICKLY
AND SP 886 POINTED US IN THAT
DIRECTION AFTER THE FACT WE'VE
LEARNED THAT THERE ARE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS WE NEED TO MAKE TO
THAT LAW. TO MAKE IT AS
EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE. SP 312
DOES THAT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? TINA SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL, ALLEN. I
WROTE A GILL ARCH ILETO. BY
ASHBY. AYE, ATKINS. I BECKER I
BLAKE SPEAR, BRADFORD. CAVIAR
OH, BRADFORD, I CAVIAR Ó. BY
CORTEZ E. DOLLY! DODD. I DURAZO.
AYE, EGGMAN. AYE, GLASER. I.
GONZALES GROVE. I THOUGHT, OH,
JONES. LAIRD. NÓ LIMÓN. AYE,
MCGUIRE. I MEAN, JABBAR. I MEAN,
AYE, NEWMAN. I WHEN I KNEEL Ó.
AYE. TODAVÍA I AM PORTANTINO.
RATH. AYE, RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO.
AYE, SKINNER. SMALL GREVERS.
AYE, STERN. HAMBURG I HAB BY
WIENER. AYE, WILK. AYE.
SECRETARY POLICE CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS. BLAKE SPEAR. GOOD TO
SEE. DOLLY? AYE. JONES.
PORTANTINO STERN. 34 KNOWS ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON A FILE ITEM 89. THE
SOONER ALVARADO GAIL PREPARED
SHE IS SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
STANDARD RESOLUTION 55 BY
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL RELATIVE TO
CERVICAL CANCER AWARENESS MONTH.
SENATOR FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION 55
RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF JANUARY
AS CERVICAL CANCER AWARENESS
MONTH AS A SURVIVOR OF CERVICAL
CANCER. THIS RESOLUTION HITS
HOME FOR ME. ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY, THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY 14,000 NEW
CASES IN THE U. S THIS YEAR. AND
NEARLY 30 30% OF THOSE CASES
WILL BE FATAL. I WEAR TEAL AND
PINK TODAY TO ENSURE THE JOURNEY
OF THOSE COURAGEOUS WOMEN.
CERVICAL CANCER IS THE FOURTH
MOST COMMON CANCER IN WOMEN
GLOBALLY. ADDITIONALLY CERVICAL
CANCER DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS WOMEN OF COLOR. THE RISK
OF HISPANIC WOMEN DEVELOPING
CERVICAL CANCER IS 1.5 TIMES
GREATER THAN IT IS FOR NON
HISPANIC, WHITE AND ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN. WHILE
THE RATES OF CERVICAL CANCER ARE
SIMILAR BETWEEN BLACK WOMEN AND
WHITE WOMEN, THE DEATH RATE FOR
BLACK WOMEN WITH CERVICAL CANCER
IS TWICE AS HIGH AS IT IS FOR
WHITE WOMEN. THESE ARE THERE ARE
USUALLY NO SIGNS OR SYMPTOMS OF
EARLY CERVICAL CANCER. BUT MOST
CASES OF CERVICAL CANCER CAN BE
STOPPED IF CAUGHT EARLY. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE AND RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT PREVENTION
METHODS, INCLUDING REGULAR
SCREENINGS AND THE OPTIONAL HPV
VACCINE. MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN
WONDERING WHY YOU RECEIVED A
DONUT THIS MORNING. WELL, THESE
DONUTS ARE A SYMBOL OF CIVIL
CERVICAL CANCER AWARENESS. THEY
COME IN DIFFERENT COLORS TO
MIMIC THE VARIOUS SKIN TONES
THAT CERVICAL CANCER DOES NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST. I'D LIKE
TO THANK STAR DONUTS OF JACKSON,
A FAMILY OWNED BUSINESS THAT IS
IN MY DISTRICT FOR PREPARING
THESE DONUTS TODAY FOR OUR
PRESENTATION. I ASKED THAT
BEFORE YOU ENJOY THIS WONDERFUL
TREAT THAT YOU SCHEDULE YOUR
REGULAR PAP SCREENING AND IF NOT
FOR YOU FOR LOVED ONES. WE ALL
HAVE IMPORTANT WOMEN IN OUR
LIVES AND NO WOMAN IS IMMUNE
FROM THE RISK OF CERVICAL CANCER
, SO I URGE THAT ALL WOMEN
PRIORITIZE THEIR HEALTH BY
SPEAKING WITH THE TRUSTED
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER, AND I URGE
MEN AND THOSE WHO DO NOT HAVE A
CERVIX TO LEARN ABOUT THE CERVIX
AND TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITHOUT THE STIGMA OF GENDER.
THAT'S WHAT EVERYONE'S TALKING
AROUND THE FLOOR, RIGHT? OKAY.
BY NORMALIZING ROUTINE EXAMS AND
TAKING CONTROL OF YOUR HEALTH.
WE CAN END THE STIGMA TO ENSURE
THAT NO WOMEN HAVE TO FACE THIS
BATTLE ALONE. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT AND VERY PERSONAL
TOPIC. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY CHANGE AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
WROTE A GILL. HI, ARCH ALITO.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKE SPEAR, BRADFORD. AYE,
CABALLERO. AYE. ORTEZ E. DOLLY!
AYE DODD TERRAZZO. I EGGMAN.
AYE, GLASER. BY GONZALEZ. I
GROVE. I HEARD AUTO JONES LAIRD.
AYE, LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE I MEAN,
JABBAR. I MEAN, AYE, NEWMAN. I
WIN. AYE. MILLER. I ACTUALLY
BROKE I VIDEO PORTANTINO RATHER
AYE, RUBIO. I SEE OUR I CAN, ER
AYE. SMALL GRABBERS. I TURN
HAMBURG. I WOULD HAVE WE KNOW I
WILL. UH, SECRETARY POLICE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BLAKE SPEAR,
ORTEZ E. JONES. BUT YEAH, AYE.
PORTANTINO STERN. WOW.
34 NO. ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
RETURN BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF
FLOOR SENATOR DOT ARE YOU
PREPARED? HE IS DOT FLOOR,
GEORGE. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE A WARM SENATE. WELCOME TO
THE NURSE. AND IT'S EASY
OLOGISTS. WHO HERE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WITH US DURING NATIONAL
NURSE AND ASTROLOGY,
ANESTHESIOLOGY WEEK IN THE
GALLERY ABOVE. WE HAVE EMILY
FRANKIE MELANIE ROW SANDRA BOARD
E. ELIZABETH BAM BOWS. KIMBERLY
BARRIS AND LOUISA MOYAMOYA.
THESE WOMEN HAVE GONE ABOVE AND
BEYOND IN THEIR NURSING CAREERS
BY OBTAINING ADVANCED DEGREES
AND WORKING EXTENSIVE CLINICAL
HOURS IN ORDER TO PRACTICE AS
CRN, A IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE EXPERTS ARE
HERE TAKING AWAY THEIR TIME FROM
THEIR PATIENTS TO EDUCATE US ON
THE IMPORTANCE AND LONGSTANDING
HISTORY OF THEIR PROFESSION, AND
PRESENCE HERE WITH US MEANS A
LOT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
THESE HARDWICK WORKING
PROFESSIONALS TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WELCOME WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR.
MEMBERS. WE'RE RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS
THE TIME FOR A JOURNEY MEMORIES.
WE HAVE SENATOR RUBIO. SENATOR
RUBIO. YOU PREPARED. SENATOR
RUBIO. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
CLAUDIA HELLER, A HISTORIAN,
EXPLORER AND COLUMNIST WHO
PASSED AWAY DECEMBER 11TH 2023
AT THE AGE OF 79. CLAUDIA WAS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE DOHERTY
HISTORICAL SOCIETY AND WOMEN'S
CLUBS. SERVING AS A STEWARD TO
THE CITY'S HISTORICAL MUSEUM AND
FOR MORE THAN 30 YEARS, WROTE A
COLUMN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEWS GROUP. IN HER
COLUMN SHE CONTRIBUTED GREATLY
TO PROMOTING AND PRESERVING THE
CAPTIVATING HISTORY OF DOHERTY
WITH HER HUSBAND, ALLEN. THEY
WORKED TOGETHER ON THREE BOOKS
LIFE ON ROUTE 66 TOWARD EAST
CHRONICLES AND CURIOSITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT. SHE WAS ALSO
NOMINATED AND RECEIVED IN A WAR
FOR A VOLUNTEER OF THE YEAR IN
2012 BY THE FORMER DOHERTY
MAYOR. CLAUDIA WAS DESCRIBED TO
BE SOMEONE WITH VERY FEW SPOKEN
WORDS. YET THROUGH HER WRITING.
SHE SHOWED HER SINCERITY AND
KNEW HOW TO USE THE RIGHT WORDS
TO CAPTURE THE MOMENT, A
CHAMPION OF LOCAL HISTORY AND AN
AVID PARTICIPANT IN THE
COMMUNITY, CLAUDIA HELLER, WILL
BE MISSED BY ALL WHO KNEW HER.
PLEASE JOIN ME MEMBERS IN A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF CLAUDIA
HELLER. THANK YOU. OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES. PLEASE BRING THE
NAME FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR PATROL BULK. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF BILL HARRISON, WHO
PASSED AWAY ON SEPTEMBER 23RD
2023 AT THE AGE OF 81 AFTER
BRAVELY BATTLING ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE. BORN IN OHIO, BILL WAS
A LONGTIME RESIDENT OF SAN
BERNARDINO. HE GRADUATED FROM
DECEMBER DINO HIGH SCHOOL IN
1960 WENT ON TO EARN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT UC RIVERSIDE IN 1965.
IN 1969 BILL AND HIS WIFE,
GLORIA. OH, FOUNDED CHICANO.
LATER THEY ADDED. THREE MORE
LOCAL NEWSPAPERS INFORMED INLAND
EMPIRE COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS,
EACH OF WHICH FOCUSED AND
COMMUNITY NEWS. BILL IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE OF 58 YEARS, GLORIA,
HIS SON, WILLIAM, AND DAUGHTER
IN LAW. LISA, HIS GRANDSON, TY.
AND GRANDDAUGHTER JESS AND
SEVERAL NIECES. AND NEPHEWS. HE
WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS
DAUGHTER, DIANA. TO HONOR BILLS
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE WILLIAM B. HARRISON
SCHOLARSHIP IS BEING ESTABLISHED
TO ASSIST THE STUDENT ATTENDING
SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY COLLEGE
WHO IS JUGGLING BOTH ACADEMIC
AND WORK OBLIGATIONS. LOVING
HUMBLE KIND, DEDICATED THESE ARE
SOME OF THE WORDS USED TO
DESCRIBE BILL BY HIS FAMILY.
JOURNALISM COLLEAGUES AND THOSE
WHO MENTORED BILL HAD A LIFELONG
QUEST FOR KNOWLEDGE AND A DESIRE
TO SHARE WITH OTHERS. HE
PRESERVED THE STORIES AND
HISTORY OF THE INLAND EMPIRE.
AND FOR THIS, WE OWE HIM A DEBT
OF GRATITUDE. I WISH BILL'S
FAMILY AND MANY FRIENDS, PEACE
AND COMFORT DOING THIS TIME OF
DEEP SORROW. I WOULD BE HONORED
IF THIS BODY WOULD ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES.
PLEASE BRING THEIR NAME FORWARD
SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS CENTER. ATKINSON
JUST IS CLEAR. MR PRESIDENT.
THANKS SO MUCH. COLLEAGUES HAVE
A GREAT WEEKEND. OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY.
JANUARY 29TH 2024 AT 2 P.M. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
330 PM, AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE,
WILL WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT
TWO PM.